[Music]  as a huge fan of superheroes I am  equally a fan of fantasy books so having  the opportunity to mash two things that  I love so much it makes me incredibly  happy turning Batman into an actual  night was pretty easy really he is  essentially a Witcher he is finding  magic in the world and stopping it but  we talked a lot about what places would  look like but largely when you're  working with someone like yours from  future who is so so good at this and so  detailed I just know that if I say it's  kind of this Yasmine will say it's this  on page four we do something that's  never been done in a DC book before and  by page 26 which is the last page of  issue one I  pretty much guarantee that we'll have  every DC found on board yeah you wait  [Music]